Thomas's favorite color Thomas's
favorite colors are blue and green he is
one blue shirt one green shirt one blue
hat one green scarf one blue pair of
pants and one green pair of pants thomas
selects one of these garments at random
let a be the event that he selects a
blue garment and let B be the event that
he chooses a shirt which of the
following statements are true and they
all let's see it before I even read them
they all about a deal with probability
of event a probability of event B
probability of B given a probability of
a given B probability of a and B so
actually let's just calculate these
things ahead of time before we even look
at these right over here so let's just
think about let's just think about
probability of a the probability of a
that's the probability that he picks a
blue that he selects a blue garment so
how many equally likely outcomes are
there well there's one two three four
five six equally likely outcomes and how
many involve selecting a blue garment
well there's one two three of the
equally likely outcomes involve
selecting a blue garment so he has a 3/6
or 1/2 probability of selecting a blue
garment now let's what's probability of
B what's probability of B and I'll do
this in a new neutral color since we're
just saying that he's B is just the
event that he chooses a shirt so once
again there's six possible items equally
likely outcomes here and which involve a
shirt
well there's one there is two so it
looks like two of the six involve
picking a shirt or we could say the
probability of B is equal to one-third
now what's the probability of a given B
let's write that down what's the
probability of we just in a new color
what's the probability probability of a
given B I'll do those in the colors a
given that B has happened so this is
saying what's the probability what's the
probability probability of a given B is
the probability that he picks a blue
garment given that he has picked a shirt
so this the given B that restricts our
outcomes to these two and so the
probability that he's picked a blue item
well that's one out of the two equally
likely ones so there is a 1/2
probability that he picks a that he
picks a blue garment given that he's
picked a shirt and that's because
there's one blue shirt and one green
shirt now let's look at the probability
of B given a probability of B given a B
given probability of B given a so
assuming that we've picked a blue
garment so assuming we've picked a blue
garment so it's either that one that one
or that one what's the probability that
we have also chose 2 what's the
probability that we have also chosen a
shirt well there's one two three
possibilities equally likely
possibilities where we have a blue
garment and only one of those involves a
shirt so probability of B given a is
one-third and then finally we could
think about probability of a and B so
the probability probability of a and and
B a and B so this is the probability of
picking a blue shirt so only one out of
the six equally likely outcomes is a
blue shirt so this one right over here
is going to be one one over six so now
that we figured out all of that let's
see if we can answer these questions the
probability of a given B equals the
probability of a and that does work out
probably if a given B is one-half and
that's the same thing as the probability
of a the probably that so that Thomas
selects a blue government given that he
has chosen a shirt is equal to the
probability that Thomas selects a blue
garment yep that's
so they I guess the words are just
rephrasing what they wrote here and I
guess more mathy notation so this is
absolutely true the probability of B
given a is equal to the probability of B
yep probability of B given a is 1/3 and
the probability of B is 1/3 the
probability that Thomas selects a shirt
given that he's chosen a blue garment is
equal to the probability that Thomas
selects a shirt yep that's right events
a and B are independent events
independent events so a two events are
independent if the if if let me write it
more in math notation these are
independent if the probability of a
given B is equal to the probability of a
then we could say a and B are
independent because the probability the
probability of a if this is true that
this means the probability of a given B
actually isn't dependent on whether B
happened or not it's the same thing as a
probability of a this would lead to
these events being independent also if
you had probability of B given a is
equal to the probability of B same
argument that would mean they're
independent or if we say that the
probability of a and B and B is equal to
the probability of a time's the
probability of B then these would also
mean they're independent and we know
that this one's true and the probability
of a and B is 1/6 and probability of a
times probability of B is 1/2 times 1/3
which is 1/6 so all of these are clearly
true so we can say that a and B are
independent the probability of a is
independent of whether B has happen or
not the probability of B happening is
independent of whether a has happened or
not the outcome event of events a and B
are dependent on each other no that's
the opposite of saying that they're
independent so we're not going to we can
cross that out probability of a and B is
equal to probability of a times
probability of B yet we already said
that to be true 1/6 is 1/2 times 1/3 the
probability that Tom selects a blue
garment that is a shirt is equal to the
garment multiplied by the probability
that he selects a shirt yep that's
absolutely
absolutely right so actually this was a
lot of these statements are true the
only one that's not is that the outcome
of events a and B are dependent on each
other